[Music]
a lot of people heading to the airport
today welcome back to cbs morning 7 30
now two days before christmas eight days
before the new year and millions of
americans are already on their way to
holiday destinations that is despite the
latest coveted surge
aaa is saying that more than 109 million
people will travel 50 miles or more
between today and january 2nd and more
than 6 million are expected to fly that
is a
184 percent increase over last year cbs
news senior travel advisor peter
greenberg joins us now with what you
need to know peter good morning great to
see you a lot of people are rusty when
it comes to travel they didn't go
anywhere last year what do they need to
know as they walk out the door this
morning
boy where do you start first of all
you've got to pack your patients
understand the staffing levels are still
a problem at airports airlines hotels
restaurants anywhere you need to go
they're not going to fix those staffing
problems until march or april next year
at the earliest so you know get ready
for delays either way you look at it and
of course the intangible weather
yeah what about cancellations are there
more
people backing out then was expected is
this a a lighter travel season than
anticipated
well i'll give you a qualified yes on
international trips people are canceling
their trips but that doesn't mean
they're going to not travel in fact
they're rebooking on plan b or plan c of
their destination in this country in
fact u.s airlines are reporting no
uptick in cancellations they're going to
be full about 90 to 95 load factors in
fact united airlines says they're on
track to fly 420 000 passengers every
day
peter we live in a world where testing
policies change on a daily basis how can
international travelers prepare for what
could be testing at these places
well nate they're not just changing on a
daily basis they're tasting on an hourly
basis so what we're seeing right now is
you can't keep up with the changes
switzerland for example got rid of their
mandatory quarantine on december 4th now
they're adding additional testing when
you enter the country thailand which got
rid of their mandatory quarantine just
reinstituted it on a 10-day basis which
means they've essentially closed the
country so my advice is this is not the
time to just go online to the cdc or a
consulate for a country get on the phone
and have a conversation with a travel
agent or travel advisor who can walk you
through the latest or you could be
disappointed
i never get travel insurance peter do
you think we should do that now in these
uncertain times
well in theory it's a great idea to do
it but that was the number two level of
complaints in 2020 and this year among
passengers who bought insurance only to
find out it was worthless because for
most people who book online you can't
complete the travel transaction unless
you opt in or opt out of the insurance
and you have no idea what you're buying
what you're covered and most work and
even worse what you're not covered for
so my advice is once again talk to a
human being who can a third party don't
necessarily buy it from the airlines or
the travel provider so they can walk you
through the hieroglyphics of that policy
language so not only do you know what
you're covered for but most importantly
what you're not covered for
the hieroglyphics is right yeah it can
be hard to find a human being though it
really can't no what happens if you're
traveling and you get stuck and you have
to quarantine because you tested
positive does travel insurance cover
that cost or is that out of pocket for
you
some of it doesn't in fact in some
countries right now uh like costa rica
the turks and caicos you're actually
required to buy an insurance policy it
goes out to about ten dollars a day
which will cover you for that many
resorts and destinations especially in
the caribbean and mexico offer another
opportunity to get you there in the
first place saying that if you do test
positive they'll pay for you to
quarantine at their expense and at their
location and they'll fly you back again
this requires a conversation you don't
do this online
yeah it's hard to get a person on the
phone no peter just saying pack your
patience that was number one that was
tip number one peter greenberg thank you
so much we appreciate you giving us the
information that we need to know